this is a production of Cornell
University yeah I just welcome everybody
and today our guest is as we're talking
about all the way from California
Maggie Ryder is a turf grass and
horticulture extension specialist out
there in California
I think Fresno County right right that's
yeah that's right so Maggie's here today
well you know as always we'll take some
questions from you guys on a variety of
topics but we did want to kind of focus
in on some glyphosate alternatives today
organic options non chemical options so
that's the conversation we'll get into
later
so with that Frank let's hear about the
last kind of week and how things are
shaping up here
thanks again Maggie for joining us just
a big shout out to Rodney Smith he's
become quite a celebrity within the turf
grass community seems to be you know
cutting lawns for this veterans old
folks people can't afford it it's got a
little service that's raising young man
big shout out to the people that are
supporting each other during these
challenging times of course in much more
difficult work than we're embarking upon
right now so again just a note from me
and personally on some way and another
way from Cornell that you know we're all
trying to manage our way through this
there's not a lot of answers I think
we've gotten maybe used to accepting
some definitiveness in and of course if
as a scientist you know nothing is
definitive but what is important is that
we work together and that's been the
nature of what we've been trying to do
here as this is our fourth time doing it
so we're already at this a month just a
reminder the extension disaster Network
is there through Cooperative Extension I
know Maggie's probably got the same
thing out there with in the UC system so
just you know shout out to stay stay
aware of the things that are happening
they're happening rapidly although now
that the governor's sort of locked us
down for a little bit longer in New York
State it appears more informations going
to be coming out about the rollout of
the economy and and while some places
are going to keep locking down
especially closer to the city other
places may roll out
it's important that you understand these
things and that we adapt to them
effectively and and again the
professional organizations the pgms
National Association of landscape
professionals not only is a good you
know connection to CDC OSHA and federal
safety guidelines but how these things
that are being implemented back into the
lawn and landscaped grounds management
area right I mean how you're gonna do
your crews is there gonna be a Plexiglas
in a truck between two workers or you're
just going to send five trucks when you
need five workers at a location when you
have equipment is everybody going to get
their own car everybody gonna get their
own weed whacker everybody gonna get
their own mower everybody gonna get
their own spray bottle masks all the
things that we're going to be using it's
good to stay abreast of these things
because if you are going to work and you
know the landscape industry is that work
there's a couple of things going on
you're gonna have to figure out how to
work safely until there's a vaccine of
any kind it appears to me as if
everybody's going to be keeping a little
more distance from each other and at the
same time people are going to call you
out on it one of the things about the
things we do is we do them right in
front of the public and that's part of
our conversation today we're Maggie you
know we do these things out in the open
we manage people's lawns and landscapes
at their house is few things more
intimate than that than just coming in
and cleaning the place so you know
you're not only got to do this to keep
your work for safety but it also is the
face of your organization now as we move
to this new normal and we're trying to
help you know we still write about it in
our 21st year write about and journaling
the growing season we continue to
publish these things and you can
actually get this information on a
weekly basis and send an email over to
Carl and he'll be happy to sign you up
for those of you in the grounds
management area just another shout out
to the school facility manager
Management Institute here in New York
State the school buildings and grounds
folks there's other grounds associations
this one's been doing a survey if I look
at that little bar chart up at the left
there you'll see that the majority of
districts have limited some form of
limited main
but if you look a little bit below the
yellow and blue bars are about to change
over the last week more or getting at or
near full capacity and they're doing
some preventive work so work is underway
it looks like it there's some aspects of
society that people feel might not be
essential I think that word essentials
getting us a little tripped up but might
be safe to do with the right safeguards
now I think all of this is the curves
got to go down right all of this is we
still can't exceed our hospital health
care systems ability to handle the sick
people as they come in addition to the
normal sick people who get sick that's
what people forget there's still all
this pressure on the healthcare system
so if we're going to work right we're
going to go to near full staff let's
make sure we're doing it safely and
again the new normal is going to include
a lot more sanitation all right that's
enough of that let's talk about growing
grass and then get with Magni about some
other interesting things here's the way
it looked when we started in soil
temperature as you can see we're still
in the 30s through much of the Northeast
now last week I'm sorry you could see it
warmed up and this is going to track air
temperature right track the two inch
soil temperature is going to track air
temperature to a certain degree and this
week we bragged about if you already saw
the sports turf one yesterday you saw we
had snow on the ground and we have more
snow again today so the soil
temperatures you can imagine is returned
into the 30s but is creeping again into
the low 50s in the metropolitan New York
area now the forecast how much heat are
we going to get well looks like right
now we're almost single digits for much
of the northeastern United States and
that means soil temperatures they're
gonna move not gonna move very much and
that means the potential for the grass
to blow isn't gonna go very much right
now in urban areas this is different in
metropolitan areas especially the New
York metropolitan area the heat island
effect forsythias are already green and
gold Jerry Jared I know from Cooperative
Extension in Westchester County shout
out to Jerry looking around the
magnolias have lost their flowers the
for cynthia's are green and glow they've
been
for a month real in real good plant
people like Jerry it's a glorious
springtime it's a glorious springtime
and the cool weather is keeping the
blossoms on longer you know it's so
funny how time how many times we
complain about all the sudden it turns
80 degrees we don't have a spring here
we get the most beautiful spring we've
had in a really long time and we're
locked in our houses to a certain extent
except you guys work but here's what's
not really happening the grass isn't
growing crazy I'm not gonna go over and
mowing Heights and growth rates what I'm
going to tell you is let's first start
with how you fertilize right there's a
leak we're gonna provide you two links
to all the resources we talked about
here today as we always do but these
clean water guidelines for fertilizing
urban turf right the basis the sort of
what we're operating on for BMP
fertilizer management in the Northeast
encourage you to get access to this to
this information it's for all of New
England right it includes a lot of
information for New York State it's the
way we promote fertilization you better
be sure you're following these
guidelines if you're out and about
working now if you're lowing you know my
hope is with less staff especially on
grounds or large Long's where you can
use zero turn mowers that you're not
developing this new disease we will see
sometimes popping up in landscapes call
zero turn mower patch the pathogen is of
a large living organism that drives this
big piece of metal around and seems to
want to turn really fast to cut the
grass so obviously we still want to be
careful out there and of course in
addition to this is the the wet ground
and the potential for rutting and
causing more damage so again if you're
getting out and mowing check your soil
moisture we had a couple inches of rain
last week we're going to get a couple
we're gonna get another inch or so this
week the grass is still not pushing
growth really hard don't go out and
cause more damage that you've got to fix
later on so I would still say based on
the weather forecast what I think the
best management
this is for fertilization are right now
past management practices are for
fertilization and and weed control and
things like that you know you still
don't have to rush out you can be
cleaning up clean up the leaf piles we
know that's where ticks are accumulating
so let's get out there and clean those
things but let's hold off on many the
other aspects now as we transition to
chatted with our yesterday one of the
things that keeps coming to mind with me
particularly as we get going is is
because we're working in the public eye
because we might be short-staffed you
know a lot of us might have to be
working amongst people walking around
because we have less people the same
number of hours in the day have to get
the work done you're going to be out and
about and you're gonna have to be
managing areas that require some level
of complete vegetation control right now
historically fence line sidewalks these
sorts of things they're a big part of
the built environment they're a big part
of lawn landscapes they're a big part of
grounds management right they're not the
kinds of things we talk about with
growing degree days and other sorts of
things but soon this education if not
already coming up is coming up and
there's going to be concerned about well
can i I got to keep these things under
control now the short term and long term
options no matter what options we're
going to talk about today it starts with
identifying what you got so another big
shout out to Jenni gown if these group
that developed the turf weeds ID guide
that we have on the web that our own
Carl skom NT did a wonderful job at
narrating the use of it for a particular
weed with line drawings and other things
big big shout out to doing this so
obviously you want to identify it in New
York State Maggie's got all kinds of
resources and there's all kinds of
resources around the country to help you
identify I'm a big fan of the Purdue
Extension publication that aaron has
ever patent has led to charge on because
it's got New York based information in
it right this is good chemical I mean if
you want to attack tile
copy you can order a copy of this I
think there is a move to get this online
but in the meantime certainly Jenny's
website will serve good alright so now
you know what you got and historically
the move was round up the move was
glyphosate the move was put a backpack
on a guy put him around there squirt
these areas when nobody's looking and
hope nobody asks if we use any
glyphosate because you know many
operations
you know turf operations that are paid
to grow grass for a living don't don't
use a lot of roundup in the grass itself
we tend to wind up using it in those
places that are difficult now Jenny
again the crew in the weed management
program here has a section of the turf
ID website that is on pesticide free
management that addresses some of these
areas in addition to playing fields and
you notice you know there's something
funny a playgrounds in many areas are
closed now
one of the things that a lot of grounds
people we're dealing with it with regard
to playgrounds currently they're closed
now if they open up you can bet you're
gonna have serious sanitation
requirements in these sorts of things
but let us not digress we're talking
about these other areas where we use
would normally use things like
glyphosate for control and of course
Maggie made headlines across the the
turfgrass Twitter world when she put
this out in a really easy to understand
way Maggie and that's where I'll bring
you back in and just will be able to go
back and forth to the screen but let's
just start with a simple approach how
did you how do these alternatives really
shake out when it comes to control sure
Frank just like I mean just like you
showed them an image there's no
alternative
that does the exact same thing that
glyphosate will do but we do have
alternatives that have a lot of
trade-offs associated with them and
that's how I that's how I like to frame
this conversation is most of the organic
herbicides are non selective burned down
act herbacides right so it's like
they're having a physical effect on the
leaf surface it's not being translocated
it's not systemic and you're only you
know controlling that leaf area that
you'd that you're having contact with
and then you know we can even get into
things like nozzle technology and
carrier rates but overall like that you
know like the table you just showed they
they're gonna do this burn down
immediately like an hour it's like you
know I say I put out some of these
trials go wash up my equipment and I
Drive walk back by and you can already
see the burn down this happening just
after a couple hours so they get that
brown and it's blackish kind of look to
them and then you'll see the peak
control or peak injury after two or
three days so that's where they do have
an advantage is if you want yeah if you
want immediate control you know you know
in a landscape but if you can't wait you
know up to 8 to 12 days or so these are
the alternatives and these are the
roundup with them without fusillade now
not a lot of our managers use fusillade
up in this part of the world
some of them do will use it to keep the
PO and you were out of bang crash
sometimes so it's a funny product what
can get you maybe what's Avenger alright
so there are you know this is like
wedding agents or surfactants there's
probably a hundred different herbicides
out there that are marketed for being
more natural or organic or something so
we cannot possibly test them all as
researchers the way that I approach this
one here is I tried to get one from
every kind of group and again these are
not like not formal like herbicide
groups but Avenger is D limonene so it's
like that's a plant oil there's a whole
bunch of these that are plant oils right
they have names like that way limonene
you know clove oil cinnamon cinnamon oil
that type of thing that's a plant oil
then final saying I'm going to skip to
the final San Juan that's a
soap a fatty acid and that's like that's
a different group soaps or fatty acids
it's called and then we we're I'm gonna
skip down to weed farm is vinegar right
there's a lot of vinegar once and that's
acetic acid would be high so it's you
know over-the-counter vinegar that we
can buy for our kitchens it's like five
percent acetic acid the herbicides are
gonna be more like twenty percent acetic
acid or twenty five percent acetic acid
so it also means to that like you can't
just buy a vinegar out of grocery store
and expect it to work you know the
herbicide vinegars are enhanced for but
you know for that reason then so burn
out was a clove oil yeah that's so that
would be in like the plant oils and it
did not do anything in this trial and
we've seen this you know validated and a
couple other you know citations in the
literature of burnout is is not
effective I would not recommend that one
and then suppress is kind of a its own
so yeah those are the three main groups
and then we have kind of wild cards
right suppress is capric acid plus
caprylic acid and then it there's
another I guess something called a bio
link acidifier that we put with it
that's designed to lower the pH and thus
enhance control on the weeds one that's
really trending you know lately in
California is called weed Slayer and
that's a clove oil or eugenol but it has
a bacillus or and streptomyces component
to it that's a good question yeah that's
not well understood right we know what
the clove oil or the eugenol can do but
it's not clear exactly how those you
know the bacillus and the streptomyces
are working but they are working isn't
that interesting you're looking at the
combination of technologies you know
this is all driven by the fact that you
know we got spoiled and in this trial
you know you show the ranger pro but you
can actually get died quad in some of
these some of these mixtures to is
Ranger prolab the quick knockdown and it
still takes eight days to see it now
so Ranger Pro is just glyphosate yep but
you know a lot of people want to combine
finale or glufosinate with glyphosate
and that we usually do not recommend
that because if you're gonna have a burn
down you know in two to three days
you're not going to have that glyphosate
product translocated to it's you know
desirable points in the plant to provide
control so listen there's a couple of
things that come up and we can talk
about the individual chemicals because
you see really in the picture how they
go but I want to bring up the next and
also where the future might lie here
that's a longer conversation but what
I'm really interested in now is
obviously you know clearly this is gonna
require I think more labor I mean you
tell me let's start with the lay oh yeah
so yeah the labor let me you try to
share my screen here I got some slides
to perfect wait oh there it is hold on
nope
can you give me ability to share screen
just make you a co-host Maggie let's see
if allocating okay let me try again
there we go so this is a webinar that I
presented recently and and this is a
table that I use in you know once a
month in a presentation about this topic
this is the idea of trade-offs that are
associated with these different kinds of
products and I'll move quickly here but
so we have like a conventional
glyphosate product right in this case we
use roundup pro max label that's a
really popular one according to some of
our local distributors and then an
organic non-selective okay a motive
action we have signal word we'll come
back to that and PPE we'll come back to
that when we talk about safety but we
look at things like the reapplication
frequency for broadcast spray can you
see my cursor yes okay you have our
lower at reapplication frequency for
glyphosate right and you're gonna have a
higher reapplication frequency for non
selective organic herbicide you know
probably at least every two weeks active
ingredient all um-- - you're having a
or volume of active ingredient that
actually hits the landscape when we're
when we are diluting you know glyphosate
or its appropriate rates but with a
non-selective herbicides you have a very
high volume of active ingredient which
when we think about ways to measure
pesticide loads in the environment you
think about I guess active ingredient
loads and that we're not we're not
necessarily saving in that category in
fact one of the products the weed farm
that's the vinegar product that we use
is just spread out 100 percent dilution
straight out of the bottle there is no
mixing it with water at all yeah so
that's that's pretty that's a lot of
product a lot of you know how do these
well potent and then oh and then of
course cost per application area it's
gonna cost more and this is just in
terms of the product right we can we can
calculate like glyphosate cost per 1,000
square feet of sprayed area is like less
than a dollar it's like 80 cents or so
some of these organics can get up to at
least you know $10 per 1,000 square feet
you know $17 the highest I've seen is
like $30 per 1,000 square feet and then
that doesn't include the cost of all
this additional labor right so it can
get complex the sort of economic and
analysis so so what are you counseling
now that you really you know you know
you're the leading voice about this I
think internally for us not toxicology
what I like is a lot of people have
gotten involved with toxicology and
we're not packs ecologist so not that
all discussion about whether you should
argue for glyphosate completely eludes
me we're in the grass and plant business
what the hell are we talking about that
stuff but let's leave that aside so now
you're essentially saying these are all
the trade-offs
what are you what were you council
people to start to do because now with
the Coleman situation yeah less people
right when you're telling me I need more
people yeah you know I don't I'm
predicting the concern for glyphosate to
go up not down I'm I'm concerned we're
gonna be working in front of people more
not less
where do you what are your
recommendations with this information in
mind
well there's a it's kind of I guess
maybe like a flowchart almost so how
restricted are you right and this we're
really just talking about not having
glyphosate and we're kind of skipping
the whole conversation about just use
other herbicides or use pre-emergence
right it can be a can be really good
time to put these into play and kind of
remind and re-educate ourselves about
why they're useful and how they work
but if you if you had to go all the way
and you cannot use any conventional or
synthetic herbicides I you know I I
bring up this table here and I say you
need to start managing expectations it's
a it becomes like a communication thing
right an understanding of your
expectations are not gonna align with
reality probably like it's you need to
think about all these things and people
or the decision makers at least are not
thinking about all of these things that
we've outlined the things we've promoted
Maggi give us back the screen Karl let's
just go back to the three of us talking
as we get closer to wrapping up is that
you know if you want to have higher
expectations and you have lower labor
and our website we talked about fence
lines you got to put a little area
underneath there you have to think about
blowtorch I don't know I want to put
flame in people's hands but you might
have to think about something that might
make people oh that's sort of cool look
at acting oh right so I'm I think what
I'm wondering that's what I that's the
way we're approaching it is we don't
have like to say we have to think about
longer-term options there are some
serious infrastructure issues about the
way we build things you just make it
difficult to you wouldn't think people
paid for a living to grow grass the
biggest hassles they got is where they
don't want to grow anything yeah
absolutely and you know what I actually
I start every presentation saying people
forget why we even control weeds right
like they're gonna disrupt our turf
aesthetics and our functionality and our
playability and they can you know have
negative public health effects even and
it's just like people forget why we're
using rodenticides and things like that
because rodents carry disease so we you
know we've had it too good
for so long but that's you know that's
where I usually start is yeah and since
we're adapting you know global pandemic
this would be a good time to start
thinking about the adaptations to make
in your environment when people come
back and they're even more
hypersensitive now yeah the funny thing
is everybody's going to be wearing PPE
with a little camel pack and go cuckoo
so nobody sees you yes so maybe one
question for me is Frank you mentioned
really quickly just like a flaming
treatment there's I think there's a lot
of communities that are moving towards
not just glyphosate but but banning
chemicals altogether especially up in
our average in New York are there non
chemical options that are feasible like
a flame like that I know if you
electrocute the soil or there's a steam
thing are there options in that room can
I answer this okay yeah so there's like
there's a whole kind of panel of what we
just call like be full-steam earths are
lethal Heat so there's steamers there's
hot water there solarization there's
propane flames things like that and yeah
those are you know we they're starting
to be an emerging I guess strategy in
California and when I talk to you know
the manufacturers of these different
products they say we're selling we just
sold five to school districts you know
it's it's taking off they sold their
first one to a golf course a weed
steamer recently but the thing is these
you know I think the organic herbicides
are a little easier to adopt because
there's less barriers to putting them
into play right it's just you're
swapping out a liquid product for
another liquid product and you're using
the same application equipment that
you're in your staff are using the same
application in chronic swapping yes
right and when we talk about like a weed
steamer it's a complex device right and
it takes a certain level of training and
understanding for an operator to use so
they like I said they're starting to
take off but I think they're a step
behind like organic herb
it's just for that reason they can be a
little more complex in California we
have to be very very thoughtful about
throwing around fire yeah and and some
you know some different you know school
or Park districts that I've talked to
about propane flamers they say they
don't want anything that's a pressurised
device like that's just they think
that's not safe for their staff to be
using so they're you know that's one of
the reasons that it can be avoided I
suppose yeah I mean III think when we
talk trade offs the big trade-off with
with going to a flamer or a foamer you
know so funny this is what Jeff Carlson
and I were playing around with 15 years
ago when they opened the vineyard Club
we walk around he called it organic
roundup we used to live happy do it you
know I just had a graduate student
figure out some non chemical stuff which
raised money and and you know it's it's
really funny you nothing is practical
compared to chemicals nothing is
practical what you said about we sort of
been spoiled for a while we haven't
really had to worry about things things
that we forgot why we even worried about
them in the first place because there's
generations of us now who have never had
to worry about these things but you know
I refer to some of the shale de castas
work at UMass where she shows if we
don't control some of these things the
pollen and the climate change is going
to get worse for people with allergies
now I'm not suggest that we need to nuke
the place but we have to have a
different conversation about the way we
control vegetation in these public built
environment places this is what we're
talking about Maggie this is where the
built environment meets is the natural
world and we're left to have to manage
what some guy said well this looks
pretty good on a piece of paper right we
didn't wish we should have put those
strips underneath the fence lines that
would have been after that so I don't
know what other kind of questions we got
Carl we're coming up on the witching
hour yep
maybe we'll get into Laurie was asking
earlier about leaving the clippings or
the leaves on the lawn and I know we've
been talking a lot about raising mowing
Heights and historically talking about
leading clippings on the lawn and maybe
we could relate that to this weed
conversation are there any benefits to
we suppressive capabilities of leaving
things like leaves or clippings on the
lawn or is that crazy well I don't think
that the actual you know leaf material
is gonna suppress weeds necessarily but
incorporating leaves and clippings back
into the lawn serves us like a
fertilizer application right so it's
going to improve your turf health create
a more dense matrix which is the
backbone of IPM it's just having a
healthy turf and preventing weeds from
establishing and so what you don't want
though especially with these materials
if you're caught if you're spraying a
sidewalk or a bed and leaves are on top
of the weeds you're to control these are
all as I understand it maggie mostly
contact materials they burn so they
don't translocate they don't kill the
things below and so you want to get
weeds when they're younger and you'll
want to make sure you're hit yeah even
we you know it gets pretty dusty in
California too
when we have periods without rain and
that's you know that's like an
implication of weed management you know
with climate change it's only gonna be
dustier and we might have less like you
know herbicide efficacy because of dust
on the surface of plants okay yeah maybe
one more we talked briefly about fence
lines and how that's a difficult place
to control fiona was asking her can you
plant perennials under those fence lines
that will go crowd out any undesirable
weeds and that's something yet to
communicate aesthetically to your
administration if they say okay what is
this stuff thrown under the fence lines
yeah I'm the but I think the best things
under fence lines are like physical
barriers right like plastic strips and
things like that or even some type of
stone or rocks but of course that's easy
to say that's what it should be like
when it's not set up that way so you
know pre-emergents are are a great tool
to use in those types of areas too and
then
yet you can use organic herbicides but
you're going to have this higher
reapplication frequency that needs to be
accounted for and then you know managing
expectations you know thoughts about
that do you ever see people planting
deliberately planting the bottom of
fence lines with perennials or plants
that provide a different look or is that
an issue with the base of the fence
being covered like that yeah you know
well we do see perennial plants like
woody shrubs and vines and things like
that more for like security or privacy
reasons but they often incorporate a
mulch layer right at the base of that
and that can be read suppressive and
that's a little bit easier to apply
right than some permanent permanent
plastic strip so mulch
[Music]
this sounds like an area that we need to
do some research on we have a couple
questions about toxicity and risk of all
these different options Frank I think
you were addressing earlier it's hard
for the scientific community that the
toxicology community to come in
consensus on these things I think
there's a bunch of ways you can try to
measure it but a lot of those things can
be one-dimensional people use things
like rat oral ld50 that's kind of a
standard one used by the World Health
Organization EPA but again it's pretty
one-dimensional right that's a test for
racks it doesn't translate maybe other
animals and you know Maggie so we're
talking about planning treatment steam
treatments you got to think risk to your
applicators - right so we think like to
say there's a lot of cases with
applicators and developing cancer and
stuff like that but you know fire is
pretty dangerous - you know so I don't
know if we can comment necessarily on
the relative risk levels of all of these
things cuz there's so many factors that
went to it any thoughts there
I see that you've got the public
concerned about this at a heightened
level for a variety of reasons whether
it's you know glyphosate it's a real
risk or because it's connected to GMOs
and people really are very uncomfortable
about genetically modified organisms may
connect that the Roundup Ready you know
corn and then that whole thing comes
together is what why I think there was
this big outlash that been fueled this
whole other thing went a little bit of
crack and science said it's a probable
whatever so I think you've always had
the public thing the thing that I'm
saying that's worrisome is OSHA and I
think we're now at the wake of it is
there's gonna be a lot more emphasis on
worker safety protection now you've seen
this in other social democracies I mean
you go to Australia they don't play
football on a field unless the field
meets certain safety criteria now that's
only been recently adopted in the United
States so I just want to say whatever
risk or safety perspective it has to not
just be a front for what you're gonna
tell the public
you better have realistic expectations
for your workforce because I think that
is the thing that's changing the most
dramatically the public pressure you
know it's always been there it's rising
whatever I think the change that
internally our workers are growing
uncomfortable with this but Hooves us to
have a broader conversation about you
know it might be safer but more caustic
so if you're sloppy you notices maybe a
person is a little sloppy with their
work you might have accepted it in some
level now you're just no no no you can't
be doing that at all so I think it is
something we don't want to adventure
into from a risk perspective I like to
think about it operationally listen at
the end of the day somebody's got to
control that vegetation unless people
like we say Maggie are gonna accept
different and and there's going to be
some risk involved if even just leaving
it there so I'm not sure there's any
straight answer for it right and I mean
just what you said at the beginning this
is what the public wants you know one of
my colleagues seems John Rocker onei he
works in organic vineyard systems and he
always says if you're a car manufacturer
a car dealer and you have red cars and
then all sudden people want blue cars
you're gonna start selling and making
blue cars right because that's what the
public
and as I always say you know as
academics and as researchers we want our
work to inform policy and to inform
science but and this we're really back
on our heels right and we're just I'm
you know I'm trying to put data to some
of the decisions that people are making
you know way ahead to me but on the
other hand I get I do get to learn a lot
from my clientele in California who are
doing this on their own and doing some
things quite well so that's that's neat
I do always always support the
thoughtful people in the industry for
sure because that's where the real
innovation comes that's why highlighting
those national associations being
involved in professional associations is
has never been more important okay Carl
all set all set I think we got most
things answer thanks very much Maggie so
great to see you you bet yeah thanks
Maggie and everybody I liked Maggie's
research website there the Twitter
account a recent webinar she did on turf
net which really goes into detail about
a lot of this stuff so feel free feel
free to check all that out thanks Maggie
Thanks this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu